yo creo que hay que comprender el
contexto internacional en el que ha
efectuado estas declaraciones el
presidente palestino mahmud abás
queriendo llamar la atención no solo del
canciller alemán sino también de toda la
unión europea acerca de lo que entiende
que es el punto muerto en el que se
encuentran las negociaciones
de paz entre palestinos e israelíes
comparando infelizmente quizás si el
término que ha empleado era evidente que
iba a provocar una reacción sobre todo
tanto del primer ministro de las
autoridades israelíes como del anfitrión
en este caso el canciller alemán
y partiendo de la base de que hay un
consejo el consenso de no llamar
holocausto a las acciones de israel en
palestina como nos deberíamos referir a
ellas bueno efectivamente nos quedamos
muchas veces con los nombres las
etiquetas nos perdemos en vericuetos de
los significados de las palabras y
perdemos de vista todas las acciones
acometidas y todas las tácticas
empleadas tanto por los distintos
gobiernos de israel como por el ejército
israelí para discriminar para hostigar e
incluso para asesinar a civiles
palestinos
ayer mismo autoridades israelíes
tuvieron que reconocer que el 7 de
agosto pasado asesinaron a cinco menores
a cinco niños pequeños palestinos en la
franja de gaza en un infeliz ataque
contra un cementerio con lo cual es
evidente que la reacción que ha sido de
condena por parte de alemania un tanto
tardía porque se le critica solos como
bien indicaba no haber respondido
inmediatamente a las palabras del
presidente palestino pero la reacción
era evidente de parte de las autoridades
israelíes lo que cabe preguntarse
entonces como debemos llamar a lo que
ocurre dentro de israelí de palestina
ocupada es decir de cisjordania o
también de gaza con los tres ciudadanos
palestinos si no podemos hablar de
holocausto porque evidentemente no es un
holocausto tal y como entendemos el
término hoy día que designa al genocidio
que se cometió contra los 6 millones de
judíos y también la etnia gitana por el
régimen nazi como deberíamos llamar a lo
que está haciendo israel contra los
palestinos por eso yo digo que no hay
que perderse en el significado de esas
palabras y de la etiqueta y realmente ir
a los hechos de fondo que son la
ocupación de buena parte de palestina
todavía por el ejército israelí y la
política de segregación y de
hostigamiento a los ciudadanos
palestinos en esa rueda de prensa vas
fue preguntado sobre una posible condena
a los atentados de múnich en 1972 lejos
de condenarlos desató esta polémica
usted ha hablado del contexto en el que
se ha producido a todo esto precisamente
por ese contexto como es la relación de
la autoridad palestina con la violencia
pasada y actual y me refiero se ve
comprometida por la fuerza de los grupos
islamistas palestinos
yo creo que en realidad volver a
preguntar a marmota vas por un suceso
que ocurrió en 1972 y que es lamentable
y criticable no ayuda a solucionar la
situación hoy dentro de palestina y así
como hubo atrocidades que se cometieron
por grupos violentos palestinos en aquel
momento las guerrillas lo que eran lo
que fue el germen de la o lp fatah y
todas las organizaciones que querían
defender la causa palestina incluso vía
la violencia después sabemos que eso
remitió cuando ya arafat y cuando el
gobierno de israel de turno firmaron la
paz y se y se concretó en la creación de
la autoridad nacional palestina hoy
llamada autoridad palestina entonces
entiendo que ya no hay razón para seguir
hostigando por algo que pasó en el
pasado a una parte del conflicto sino
también investigar qué está pasando hoy
día con las violaciones a los derechos
humanos en concreto de los palestinos
entonces me parece que este tipo de
preguntas son un tanto un dardo
envenenado rodrigo y que muchas veces
sembré tan los presidentes los políticos
se metan en responderlos cuando en
realmente lo que tendríamos que estar es
cuando van a tornar a retornar a la mesa
de negociación los palestinos y los
israelíes para dar una solución
definitiva creíble y veraz a la
situación que se vive en el país porque
israel tiene derecho a vivir en paz pero
también los palestinos tienen su derecho
y su legítima razón a la hora de exigir
un estado independiente y soberano